Using a game engine for linear animation can be intimidating for the uninitiated.
It requires learning new terminology that the average DCC software user is unlikely
to be familiar with.
Being very modular in nature, Unreal breaks down its world construction and animation
features with an array of new technical engine terms that unfortunately have no equivalent
in classical digital film production.
These terms are directly related to the process of building a game, but once you learn them,
you'll come to appreciate their capabilities and logic.
Static meshes and scale meshes describe different types of actors based on whether they have
a joint-based deformable geometry.
Unreal also uses different terms for objects in the scene, like actors, pawns, and characters.
The environment is described in terms of the world, maps, levels, and sub-levels.
Control rigs are like animation rigs.
Terms are used for triggering specific actions or different visual looks.
Blueprints are a visual scripting system, and source control is a way to check data in and
out of your project using a server depot.
However, Sequencer's feature set attempts to mirror some of the terminology you're
more familiar with in film production, like scene assemblies, takes, layout, shots, and sequences.
It's not a coincidence that Sequencer's level sequence and assembly structure bears
a certain similarity to the organization of film production.
A typical film is broken down into acts, sequences, scenes, shots, and takes.
Each unit is smaller than the last, and they effectively are nested inside of one another.
On the Unreal side, Sequencer is designed to replicate film structure by using level sequences.
These actors can create levels of organization through nesting level sequences into one another.
This will allow organizational control over scenes, actors, cameras, lights, keyframes,
and other technical capabilities.
Since level sequences are essentially virtual containers, they are capable of handling
greater and greater orders of animation complexity as more level sequences are added to them.
For new users, it can be confusing to realize that the level sequence actor can accommodate
so many different tasks while still being called a level sequence.
You may hear me say things like level sequence shot, or level sequence sequence, but they're
all level sequence actors being used in different ways.
Try not to be confused by the words level sequence.
As promised, here's an example of what a nested level sequence looks like so we can
compare it to what you'll be constructing in a single level sequence during the hands-on
exercise.
It consists of a parent level sequence with multiple level sequence shots inside of it.
The parent level sequence can possess multiple level sequence shots through the use of a
shot track.
Level sequence shots can be moved, they can be trimmed, or have their play rate altered.
You can even generate new takes of shots by using our take system.
And if you'd like, you can add a fade track to fade up from black.
The structure of a nested level sequence can be nearly anything, especially for game construction
purposes, but for cinematics and linear content creation there are usually some core ingredients.
Inside each level sequence shot, you'll have level actors like props or characters to
animate.
A minimum of one camera per nested level sequence is needed, whether it's spawnable or possessible.
And most importantly, you'll need a camera cuts track to generate footage.
When played in sequence, the parent level sequence pulls camera binding data from each
shot's camera cuts track so it knows which camera it's looking through and what needs
to be rendered.
The result is a continuous sequence when played back through the timeline.
As impressive as nested level sequences are, you might not need so much complexity.
With a single camera cuts track and a single level sequence, users can construct long animated
takes and assign cuts to the camera cuts track to meet their needs.
If multiple cameras are added into the level sequence, that long animated take can easily
turn into a master shot with coverage cameras being placed throughout the scene and bound
to the camera cuts track to create an engaging sequence where continuity is easily preserved.
Let's take a look.
Now inside of this 105.1 example, you'll see that I have three cinematic cameras.
You'll only have two.
I've added the third for demonstration purposes.
But these three cinematic cameras, camera one, camera two, and camera three, they're all
bound to the cinematic camera cuts track at specific points in time.
Camera one, camera two, and camera three.
If I want an additional fourth shot, it's just a matter of clicking on the plus button
and adding a new binding.
I'll go to camera one.
Now you'll also see that I have this gray box in here.
This is what's called a camera blend and it can be activated here.
The camera blend basically blends the position of two cinematic cameras between shots and
the camera cuts track.
Let's take a look and see what this looks like.
Now this method of level sequence assembly does have its trade offs.
The level sequence can become crowded with so many actors and cameras and other effects
that it can become cumbersome to organize.
Plus in animation and VFX workflows, it's usually necessary to break down things into
separate shots for logistical purposes.
So a lot of times it all depends on what you're trying to accomplish.
Okay, this completes this demonstration.
Let's move on to our next module.